making drinks from hand for a large
group can seem like a daunting and very
time-consuming task but I'm going to
show you how to make a large batch of
drinks in a pitcher the night before
that requires no shaking and no stirring
it's called the hard Arnold Palmer for
this drink you're going to need some
bourbon fresh lemon juice simple syrup
water and black tea any generic brand
will do so unlike the traditional Arnold
Palmer we're not going to use iced tea
we're actually going to infuse bourbon
with tea so I'm going to infuse the
Bourbon first this is about two
tablespoons loose tea we're going to
fill this up with a cup and a half of
bourbon and then we're going to peel a
lemon and throw that in there because
that also soaked up some nice aromatic
citrus oils so this needs to sit for
about 20 minutes but thanks to the magic
of making drinks on camera this can now
be strained right into the pitcher using
a mesh strainer or chinois something
that'll catch that tea
and to that I'm going to add one cup of
fresh lemon juice we're going to quarter
cups of simple syrup and one and a half
cups of water so this can sit in the
fridge overnight getting cold because
the booze will help preserve the fresh
lemon whenever you're ready to serve you
can just throw some ice and glasses
mason jars and just pour them right over
but I'm going to prepare this right now
and since it has been in the fridge I'm
going to throw some ice in there to
chill it down I'm also going to add some
lemon wheels to make it look nice the
hard Arnold Palmer is a refreshing drink
it's not too strong it's absolutely
perfect for enjoying with a big group of
friends for those long afternoons on the
fairway if you liked that recipe tell us
some of the favorite cocktails you like
to make at home in the comments below